In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion for September 16, on which we commemorate the Holy
martyr Ludmila, Princess of the Czechs.
Saint Ludmila, the grandmother of St. Wenslas, Prince of the Czechs, was the wife of Prince
Boryvoi. She and her husband were instructed in the Orthodox faith and baptized by the Holy
Bishop Methodius, the Enlightener of the Slavs.
With fervent faith, the Prince and Princess did all they could to encourage their people
to become Christians. They built churches throughout their land and provided for the maintenance
of the priests that ministered in them. Prince Boryvoi died at the age of 36, having given
three sons and one daughter to Saint Ludmila, who accepted widowhood as the will of God
and bore her loss courageously. She detached herself from worldly pursuits and distributed
her wealth to the poor. Her son, Vratislav, then ascended the throne and ruled the Czech land
for 23 years. On his death, he was succeeded by his son, Wenslas, whom his grandmother,
Saint Ludmila, had brought up in the true faith and love of the Holy Evangelic virtues.
But Wenslas' wife was consumed by hatred for Saint Ludmila and sent two boyars to
strangle her in the castle of Tetin, now Detshin, where she had withdrawn to avoid discord.
Saint Ludmila received the martyr's palm in the year 920, when she was 61 years old.
How many miracles took place at her tomb that Prince Wenslas had her relics translated
to Prague, where they are venerated today in the Church of St. George.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
save us.